hey there visual politic Community my oh
my what a mess is going on in Africa the
coup d'etat in Niger means much more
than the typical seizure of Power by the
military yes it is true that Niger is
one of the poorest countries in the
world but despite this it did have a
recognized democracy it had a government
willing to ask for international help to
curb jihadism which is making the sahil
its territory in the sense Niger was the
great Ally of the West and the Heart of
the sahil now however all of this has
been blown to bits by the coup d'etat at
the end of July now niger's military
Junta is looking for foreign help but it
wants to change allies niger's Junta
asks for help from Russian group Wagner
as it faces military intervention threat
but wait just a minute because military
intervention was not offered by any
Western power concerned as they are by
the kremlin's growing influence in
Africa so help was not offered at least
not directly
it was ecowas the economic community of
West African states which is not willing
to tolerate another military coup and is
demanding the return to power of
Muhammad bazum the deposed President of
Niger and that is exactly what has set
the drums of War beating once again in
Africa 10 August 2023 West African
leaders activate standby Force to
respond to Niger coups worst of all this
military intervention could go beyond
Niger and trigger a regional conflict
that could spread to multiple countries
this is how the spokesman of the
military Junta Colonel amadu abrame put
it and pre-deployment participation is
has not hesitated to accuse a foreign
power of instigating and preparing an
attack against Niger of course he is
referring to France its former Colonial
ruler in fact the military Junta has
broken all niger's military agreements
with France the macron government merely
indicated that it supports the ecowas
intervention so you're already seeing
how things are progressing and you might
be wondering why is this coup d'etat
taking place in Niger what role is
Russia playing in all of this and above
all how many countries might this
conflict end up spreading to on
visualpolitik today we're going to
answer all of these questions but first
let's look at some history
[Music]
the last democracy of the say hell
the sahale is a narrow strip of land
south of the Sahara Desert characterized
by extreme poverty four countries are
located in the center of the sahil from
west to east we've got Mali Burkina Faso
Niger and Chad well they all have
several things in common to begin with
all of these countries are landlocked
what's more French is spoken in all four
so you can probably guess which country
was their colonial power and they are
also majority Muslim countries and now
they also have something else in common
all of them are currently governed by
the military after a coup d'etat that
put an end to the seventh Republic of
Niger and yes more than one of you will
be thinking but hold on just a second
Grant if Nigeria gained independence
from France in 1960. 63 years with seven
republics works out at nine years per
Republic right and yes that is true but
stability and Niger are two words that
do not usually go hand in hand
even so there does appear to have been a
change since 2010 a military coup in
favor of democracy ousted president
Mamadou Tanja from Power a man who had
been elected at The Ballot Box but who
aspired to keep himself in power and
turned Niger into an authoritarian
regime the transition was supported by
the International Community and resulted
in the constitution of the seventh
Republic a period that in 2021 would see
the first peaceful transfer of power
between presidents
nevertheless in the last decade the
sahale has been a serious threat to
destabilizing the entire region of
course we're talking about jihadism
religious fanaticism Finds Its soldiers
among the desperate and often starving
inhabitants of these Sahel countries
there are people who were born in one of
the worst places in the world and the
jihadists promised them a better present
and a future in paradise and of course
the problem is that the alternative is
subsistence agriculture on which more
than 80 percent of niger's population
lives in poverty in fact extreme poverty
reaches almost half of all the country's
inhabitants these figures have hardly
changed in the 13 years since the start
of the seventh Republic we are talking
about data very similar to those of
neighboring countries such as Mali and
Burkina Faso both have had coup d'etats
in the last three years that ended
democracy Mali in 2021 and Burkina Faso
in 2022 in both cases the military
seized power under the pretext of ending
jihadism however the results have been
quite the opposite take a look at this
map produced by the U best company
stratfor for violent incidents in the
sahale between August 2021 and August of
2022.
the war against jihadism has triggered
violence in 2022 jihadist's deaths in
the sahil increased by 75 to more than
10 000. chaos prevails and mali's
Military Junta has turned to the
Wagner's and Burkina Faso the government
barely controls 40 of the country in
Niger the situation is not so extreme
but the same jihadist groups that are
ravaging Mali and Burkina Faso are also
active there we are talking about
Al-Qaeda and daesh Affiliates it also
suffers constant attacks by Boko Haram
and the Islamic State on its border area
with Nigeria but unlike in Burkina Faso
and Mali last year in Niger was proving
to be the least deadly since 2018. so
the question is what is the reason for
this difference well nothing less than
the approach adopted by Niger by the
government of Muhammad bazoom against
jihadism his strategy has several steps
first of all Western military aid mainly
provided by France and the United States
second of all the Improvement of State
services in the most depressed areas and
third of all other initiatives that are
as opposed to the war against jihadism
as they are obviously controversial
Niger Muhammad bazoom releases
terrorists to open the dialogue the
bazoom-backed demobilization plan
promised to reintegrate into society
jihadists who laid down their arms so
basically dialogue in exchange for a
truce freedom and exchange for peace
from the Western point of view talking
to terrorists is a bad idea it implies
giving in to their blackmail and opens
the door to Fresh attacks in order to
achieve new concessions
however in a country like Niger the real
power of the state and the strength of
the terrorist groups must be weighed
against each other if the fight is
balanced going to war could be a
disaster for the population other
avenues must be explored and of course
there are those who are not willing to
tolerate the slightest sign of weakness
this is how the new president of Niger
General Omar takani Justified his coup
d'etat due to the alleged deterioration
of security caused by jihadisms
this is the same excuse that the coup
plotters gave in Mali and in Burkina
Faso but you have already seen that the
data from Niger is quite different so
there must be something else so the
question is what will probably the
pre-koo rumors that General trichani was
going to be removed as the head of the
presidential guard are true don't lose
sight of the fact that it was the
presidential guard that carried out the
coup by taking prison hostage the Army
had to declare itself afterwards take a
look Niger Army backs coup against
pro-western leader to prevent bloodbath
but well it's not worth giving much more
thought to all of this at the end of the
day there are military men staging a
coup d'etat to seize power whether out
of personal ambition or national
discontent for one reason or another it
is daily fodder on the African continent
nonetheless visual party Community this
time they have come up against the
direct rejection of a regional
organization such as ecowas an
organization that seems ready to do
anything to restore democracy in Niger
and take note because this would not be
the first time
[Music]
War
ecowas is an organization made up of 15
West African countries including Niger
initially it was an organization with an
economic purpose of forming a single
trade block but wait a minute because
ecowas has also mobilized peacekeepers
in the region and intervened in member
countries in times of great instability
in the last 30 years they have been
active in Sierra Leone Guinea basal
Ivory Coast Liberia Mali and Gambia
[Music]
it was in Gambia that the last ecowas
military intervention took place that
was in 2017. after two decades in power
Yaya jammeh was reluctant to relinquish
power to Adama Barrel who had won the
presidential election ecowas formed a
coalition of troops from Senegal Ghana
and Nigeria and set out to invade The
Gambia resigned after three days and
democracy was restored
even so Niger is not Gambia its
territory is 100 times larger and its
armed forces in addition to being more
numerous has years of training by
Western forces so military intervention
is complex and would involve taking many
more risks the first one the life of
president bazoom who is not in Exile but
in the hands of the coup plotters
Western officials Niger Junta warned
they'd kill deposed president after any
military intervention on top of that I'm
sure many of you are wondering why
ecowas has now been so firm and
assertive towards Niger when similar
coups have already recently taken place
in Mali and Burkina Faso
thank you
well the key to everything lies with one
person Bola tinubu he has been the new
president of Nigeria since last May
tenubu has had enough time to be
appointed president of ecowas at the
beginning of July a representative
position from which he launched this
message at his inauguration we will not
allow
cool after cool
it's Africa Brazil in his speech he also
defended democracy freedom and the rule
of law and all of this is much more than
Bola tinubu's words they are the new
Nigerian president's letter to an
introduction to ecowas to the African
continent and even to the whole world
after all we cannot forget the enormous
influence of Nigeria we are talking
about the great African power alongside
Egypt and South Africa and naturally it
was the leading voice of ecowas aside
from its concern that Niger will suffer
the same fate as Mali and Burkina Faso
and that violence in the area will
escalate Nigeria wants to assume its
role as a regional leader and the Niger
coup took place just three weeks after
tinubu's speech so long as democracy
remains unsuccessful military
preparations will continue The
credibility of Bola tinubu is at stake
ecowas contingent for invasion of Niger
May amount up to 25
000. more than half of the contingent
would be contributed by Nigeria Senegal
Ivory Coast and Benin have also
confirmed that they will send troops and
then there are two other countries with
troops on the ground one is France the
former Colonial ruler is being used by
the coup plotters as a scapegoat
everything that is wrong in Niger is
France's fault indeed the coup plotters
have attacked the French Embassy and
even accused the macron government of
releasing terrorists on top of that we
don't want to show unpleasant images but
just to let you know that the coup
plotters filled a soccer stadium and
people cheered along as they decapitated
a rooster painted with the French flag
surely with all of this you already have
an idea of the animosity they have
towards France
[Music]
well the Gauls maintain a permanent base
there equipped with fighter jets Reaper
drones and 1 500 troops the macron
government has said it supports ecowas's
efforts to return bazoom to power
however chances are that not a single
French soldier will move lest the
military Junta is here to stay an
agreement such as the one of last May
will need to be Revisited Niger
agreement signed with the French Aura
now for the exploitation of uranium
deposits until 2040. it is clear that
France's interest is to continue
exploiting uranium from Niger which has
been its third largest supplier in
recent decades then the other country
that has troops in Niger is the United
States in total there are more than a
thousand troops deployed in several
drone bases for the moment the White
House is betting on the Diplomatic route
but it is being asked to take action
niger's
ousted leader says he's a hostage and
urges U.S to Halt coup the former
president asked for it in a letter to
the Washington Post no less yes it kind
of seems difficult to understand I mean
what kind of coup perpetrators allow
their a prisoner to communicate freely
with the outside world because following
the coup bazoom posted a tweet and has
even spoken on the phone with blinken
with Charles Michelle with Burrell I
mean come on he was almost a YouTuber
nevertheless neither the White House nor
the European Union are making progress
in negotiations with niger's military
Junta the kudi leaders have even refused
to receive a tripart delegation composed
of Representatives of ecowas the African
Union and the UN and do you know what
the military is very clear about what
they want niger's place in the world to
be and who will be its allies check this
out
foreign
Beyond the Wall
the military Hunters of Mali and Burkina
Faso offer us the Playbook to be
followed by the modern African coup
plotter the first thing to attack is the
former colonial power in every possible
way they have to be blamed for
everything in the case of Niger for
example we have already shown you some
examples but wait just a moment because
they can still do more against France in
Mali for example the eliminated French
as an official language and both here
and in Burkina Faso they expelled all
the French troops that were fighting
jihadism so just a couple of tweaks I
guess be that as it may The Next Step
would be take a position within this
multi-polar world and in Niger they have
already made their choice
niger's tailors rush to make Russian
Flags after coup the coup plotters have
created a swarth of military-led
countries in Africa stretching from the
Atlantic Ocean to the Red Sea most of
these countries are now more aligned
with Russia than with the West not only
that but they intend to build a wall
against the once Undisputed Western
influence visual politic Community
neither Russia nor Wagner are involved
in the preparations for the coup d'etat
in Niger but once that has taken place
both are ready to profit from it Wagner
is spreading throughout Africa like a
virus
in fact before the pregosian Mutiny The
Mercenaries of the Wagner group were
part of the catalog of services offered
by Russia and its diplomatic
negotiations this is how Wagner is
creating a presence in countries such as
the Republic of Mali where the
authoritarian regime's higher pregosians
men to do their Dirty Work meanwhile the
Kremlin displaces the West as the
influential power in the area
Putin is very interested in Africa has
demonstrated that the summit just held
in Saint Petersburg so all indications
are that pregosian will continue his
operations on the African continent as
long as he remains useful for Putin's
purposes and you saw at the beginning of
the video that niger's military Junta
has asked the Wagner group for help a
group that is taking control of the gold
and diamond mines in the Central African
Republic in Mali and in Sudan and what
does Niger have for Wagner well mainly
uranium depriving Europe of uranium from
Niger would bring a smile to the faces
of Putin and pregosian but it does not
seem so attractive to Russian
mercenaries something else is needed and
well Niger does have the occasional gold
mine it also has oil in fact Niger was
aiming for a five-fold increase in its
modest crude oil production just this
year the thing is as though of you who
are regulars here on visualpolitik will
know Wagner is always out to make a
profit still this is the least of the
military junta's concerns the ecowas
intervention is their number one
priority right now and everything
indicates that in the case that the
intervention finally does take place the
coup plotters in Niger would not be on
their own Burkina Faso Mali say military
intervention in Niger would be
declaration of war the walls of the coup
plotters are being fortified and take
note because Algeria and guinea have
also shown their rejection of military
intervention meanwhile ecowas continues
to put pressure on the military Junta by
ordering the mobilization of its Reserve
forces to restore constitutional order
in Niger this conflict threatens to
directly involve a lot of African
countries that have already stated that
they will take up arms to defend their
possessions on visualpolitik we will
continue to follow this budding conflict
but now the questions are for you do you
think ecowas will succeed in restoring
democracy in Niger will any power
outside the African continent get
directly involved leave us your answer
in the comments below and if you found
this video interesting don't forget to
like And subscribe to all of us here at
visualpolitik all the best I hope you
enjoyed it and I'll see you next time
[Music]
thank you